[Music]
[Applause]
charles barkley hall of famer joining us
got any problem with butler taking that
three when he did
no sir okay i mean he's the only reason
he's the only reason they were alive in
that series and it's a wide open three
um
uh so i had no problem with hey jimmy
butler he proved me man and now he's a
stud man what he did in game six
and tried to do it in game seven
got nothing but love and respect for
jimmy jimmy f and butler as i call him
well there are certain guys that might
be better players but in those moments
those guys i mean jimmy butler wanted
the big moment and i i love the guy who
wants to take that shot but i think that
al horford left him open because al
wanted him to take the shot or was okay
with him taking that shot
well i don't know if al could have got
out there anyway i mean it was it was
kind of a semi-fast break
but like i said i had no problem with
jimmy taking the shot and if he makes
the shot we'd be having a different
argument we'd be saying damn jimmy
butler we need to move him up on the
line
but uh man he's just tough man
i i'm not even gonna worry about game
seven because he had zero help but what
he did in game six to me that was just
impressive who do you like in the finals
i like the celtics and six i think
they're gonna be too big for the
warriors
uh
that's just my personal opinion i think
their depth is probably gonna wear them
down
uh so i like the celtics in six
but okay do you have problems with
golden state fans does that factor in
your prediction here
no not at all dude i didn't think the
mavericks could beat the warriors as i
said i just root for them because i hate
the warriors fans you know the thing
that's interesting they used to have
great they used to have great fans and
they were over in oakland
i've said before i thought when they
were in oakland they had the best one of
the best fan bases in the nba and now
they just got a bunch of jackasses over
in san francisco but that never factors
in i like the celtics that win the
series i just think they're going to be
too big and too and their death is going
to win the search for them but why do
they have a problem with you
oh you know dan you know how fans are uh
they want you to say their best players
to greatest and their team is the best
i mean this is nothing new
but that's all fans want tell me my
favorite player is great and tim and my
team is great and if you don't do that
they don't have a problem with you i
mean that's nothing new
but that's like that's like um when i'm
in alabama you know i think garrett
danielson and vern blockers do an
amazing job and i'll be sitting around
with my friends to go to alabama and
auburn they're like gary daniels and
vern they hate us i'm like you guys are
the biggest fools in the world
dad i will tell you i do not i never
care who's gonna win a basketball game
i never care you know what i want is
vacation it's where i am right now
hey get it over with hey hey i don't
have to watch another basketball game
until
october
uh the only thing i'm watching right now
is the stanley cup playoffs because man
let me tell you something me and one of
my friends went out and watched game
seven last night that was a ranger
beatdown but
if you're not paying attention to the
lightning trying to three-peat
or in the west
if you're not with drysado and mcdavid
against mccarr and nathan mckinnon if
you're not excited about that
colorado edmonton series
if you would say first of all if you
love hockey you can't get a better four
stories
but man i cannot wait for that western
conference showdown it's gonna be
awesome to watch all those young kids
going at each other it's going to be
awesome when did you get into hockey
oh back in my flowers days with my boy
rick tockett who's on tnt now my
favorite hockey player all time is ron
hexdahl
uh you know eric lindros you know i knew
all of those guys uh and and i've been a
flyer fan ever since
and that's the last time we had a good
team i might ask
did you agree with james worthy what he
uh his assessment of nba players now
that uh they lift weight get tattoos
and uh
i don't know what shoot threes
well he's right on the three part
the only thing that concerns me
i wonder if these guys want to be great
players
i think they want their money and they
want all the stuff that goes with it
my question is and i've said this puppy
not just agreeing with james
i'm not sure how they they want to be
great players
i mean they want the money and the fame
and all that stuff hey we all do
but i think the money has gotten so
astronomical now i wonder how many of
these guys really want to be a great
great player and i i'm not saying that
being the old guy i mean i'm watching
i'm like man this guy should be
this guy should be great
this guy should be great but
i don't know if he he got he got it all
there's no reason him to be try to reach
his potential
uh the lakers hiring darvin ham
thoughts on that
well i'm glad darvin got an opportunity
um
because he's paid his dues he's a nice
guy we have to see what kind of coach he
is but listen if if one of your coaches
as close to the same age as your players
your team not going to be any good
anyway
i mean the lakers they got a serious
dilemma on their hands
i mean their best player is going to be
40.
you know anthony davis has never been
healthy you know obviously russ is going
to be there one more year so
what's really bad about the situation
next year is going to be the same as
this year and then lebron just going to
be a year older
uh and then they'll have russ off the
books and then they'll be like but
lebron's going to be a year older
and anthony
you know i thought i said last year
coming to the season i'm not worried
about lebron or anybody else if the
lakers is gonna be any good it's gonna
have to be anthony davis
i mean i said because he i said if he's
one of the top five players in the nba
the lakers can compete because you can't
be asking a 38 year old guy
to be your best player that just makes
it same thing here in phoenix i'm like
it's time for devon book and deandre
aydin to step up you can't ask 38 year
old chris paul to be your best player
especially you think about it dan he
took him all the way to the finals last
year he came back and had the best
record in the nba all year he gets them
to the second round of the playoffs
that's a lot to ask of a 37 38 year old
guy especially a guy like chris who's
miniature he's a little guy
but it's time for deandre ayden and
devin booker to step up and be
better than all stars
talking to charles barkley hall of famer
yeah i was back to the lakers with
westbrook i don't know what you can do
with him but i think it's going to be
really hard for a rookie head coach to
come in and all of a sudden figure out
how to incorporate russell westbrook
into the offense or utilize his talents
i i just think that's impossible
well because russ is stubborn
uh i i've always admired russ because
he's the hardest working player that
i've ever seen in the nba
but
he's still trying to play the way he did
five years ago
and he can't do that
you know as a player as you get older
you have to it's kind of like okay i got
to work on my strengths
uh i got and and try to limit my
weaknesses but if you watch the lakers
play
which
i've seen them play
unfortunately they'd be stuffing them
down on throat
on espn and tnt
like he trying to play the way he did 10
years ago and it's not going to work
he has to make sacrifices
he has to learn to play with dr ball he
has to really work on his shooting
and i don't know
part of his greatness is his
stubbornness and i don't know if i don't
know if at this stage of his career he
can change
we can't shoot
i know that's what i'm saying he that's
if i was rushed i'd go get reggie miller
somebody like that who lives on the west
coast and say hey
uh you know they got kyle korver he you
know he's working with ben simmons so
i'd get i said hey russ call call reggie
miller let's get in the gym and just
shoot just shoot just shoot because
the problem he's gonna have dan
if he doesn't play well this year
his nba career might be over
because who's gonna sign him if he
doesn't work on his game or he's gonna
try to want to be treated like he was
when he was mvp like six seven years ago
so this is a big year for him
robert orry is on next hour
we uh asked the question
whose career would you want basketball
career robert dory's
or yours
you know uh i like my career i know i
didn't win the championship and i'm i
love i like being myself
i i i always laugh when i'm not sure how
i got to the point where i became an
individual thing instead of a team thing
um
unfortunately
a couple of people on television started
this probably and it actually been for
the detriment of the nba
uh because
nobody told michael jordan after four or
five years you got to get out of here
you're not going to win a championship
so things started getting crazy
with lebron
and he started listening to all the
rumors about man you got to win to be
successful and then he went
went to miami and then then it happened
next with kd
uh so it started somewhere back then but
hey man i'm pretty happy with my life i
wish i could have won a championship for
these people here in phoenix
uh but i don't
i'm i'm good with my my success in my
career what's your favorite nickname
well at this stage of my life i'm either
well uh i mean the sir charles of the of
or the round-mounted rebound but
uh it doesn't matter to me it's like
when people ask me somewhere along the
way my name went from being charles to
chuck
and people ask me what do you call my
man i don't care i don't care you call
me chuck you call me charles it doesn't
even matter to me but you you embraced
it in in college didn't you but didn't
embrace it well we had well what
happened was that the uh my great coach
my father figured sonny smith came to me
one time because you know dan when i
went to auburn
we were nothing in basketball we had
never made to marge madness
uh we hadn't i actually we when i signed
with albany had lost 12 games in a row i
mean i said oh these were these guys
some bombs i should come to college here
so
after i had a good freshman year people
started taking notice and sports
illustrated wanted to do a story on me
and coach said hey we need to drum up
support for the program and i says we
need to drum up some players too
[Laughter]
so that's how that's actually how the
whole thing started and it really worked
we got chuck person
we got wesley person we got frank four
gerald white we started getting really i
mean i said i always tell people man
auburn had never had a mcdonald's
all-american we had guys who ate at
mcdonald's i mean
and we found a guy out of kissimmee
florida named frank ford he's the first
really like mr florida uh great
mcdonald's all-american player but other
than that
i was the fifth-ranked player in alabama
when i came out
i mean we had never had a top five guy
in alabama in just our state and i'm
talking about around the country in the
state of alabama we never gotten a top
five recruit
and now
since uh and i tell people one of my
greatest accomplishments was getting
auburn to the big dance i mean because
my first two years we were
below 500 my second year we were right
at 500 my third year we got to the
tournament and i'm really proud and then
i left after that but now hey we got
bruce pearl who's arguably one of the
best coaches in college and we're a
perennial contender now and i'm happy
with that
what would you do if you're the pelicans
with zion with uh contract extension
ooh man that's a really tricky one dan
uh
to give him 200 million dollars uh
that's that that that to me listen
that's the job you get paid to do
and
would i give it to him
no i would not because
he then he's never been healthy
not no and i'm not even talking about
the nba i'm talking about high school
college
nba he's never been healthy
and can i and he hasn't proven to me
that he can control his weight
uh you know i i listen don i'm not
comparing myself to him but it's the
exact same situation when i first got to
the nba i weighed 300 pounds and moses
alone the most important person in my
career made me lose 50 pounds and made
me the great player i became and i think
zion
uh
man get off my phone uh so i think john
is in the exact same boat as i am wait
who is calling you
can you hear me yeah with somebody
calling you
can you hear me now yeah i got you
okay yeah i can't hear you oh
well that's okay just talk
i can't hear you damn
man i wasn't making my point either
okay hold on for a second we'll we'll uh
we'll call you back you know let's take
a break we'll come back with charles
we'll try to reconnect with him
charles barkley kind enough to rejoin us
and uh we were talking about zion
williamson that contract extension uh
yeah you know you know i was telling
like
dan when i first got to the nba i
weighed 300 pounds
and asked moses malone who's like a dad
to me i said why am i not getting to
play he said you're fat and you're lazy
and he said charles you can't play at
this weight in the nba you can get away
with it in college but you can't play
he said let's lose 10 pounds and then he
took me to 290 to 80 to 72 60 250.
i didn't think i could lose 50 pounds
but i did
but i wonder and who in that pelican
organization would tell zod man you got
to get in shape because if you're always
hurt they tell me you're not getting in
shape
and the thing we got today we got these
players they got so much power
like if they say he said well screw
y'all i don't have to get in shape
somebody else would give me some money
somewhere else
instead of bit looking like no man i
need to get in shape so
he has not proven to me he can stay
healthy
uh
and the thing you the problem is if he
leaves and turns into the player we
think he can be you're gonna get fired
and rightfully so
but you have to make that decision
to to what it comes down to me
is who's in that building every day
do you what kind of kid do you think he
is
you think he gonna get in shape
or you think he gonna take that money
and just live happily ever after and the
only person can make that decision is
somebody who's in that building every
single day because
we know how guys are players know how
guys are
there's guys who i played with i said i
wouldn't give him a damn dime because he
because once he get paid he gonna quit
and and i've been around players like
that before that's one of the reasons we
started shorting nba contracts because
guys would have one great year when they
became a free agent and then they pack
it in until the next time they were free
agent so the nba started shorting
contracts that's how this whole thing
started about players once they get that
money you never know how they're going
to react
but you were talking about if you're
russell westbrook reach out to reggie
miller to help you with shooting
shouldn't zion reach out to you somebody
of similar size who
you know similar career or career that
you you want who you would aspire to
yeah you know if he did i tell him yo
man first of all they gonna give you
damn the most money i ever made was like
five million dollars not poo pooing on
five million dollars that's i've been
blessed i don't care about money but
somebody told me they would get ready to
give me 200 million dollars
hey i would be the skinniest
in the history of civilization
like and anything is caring about it dan
he's gonna get another 200 million in
four or five years
he should have hired his parents should
have said yo man
we're getting you a chef
we're getting you a chef
and we and like and you you you make a
deal with the
trainer and the workout people say hey
i'm gonna give y'all x amount of money
to make sure i work out even when i'm
tired but the first thing he should have
done
last year was got a private chef because
yo man everybody likes to eat but when
you have this type of money at stake i
mean think about it dan
if he gets in shape
he gonna give him 200 million dollars he
can be like 22 years old
he gonna make another 200 250 300
million when he's like 30 years old
and hey and i i never try to play god on
television yo man
take that money do you get your butt in
shape and take that money
yeah i just wonder if this resonates
with younger athletes where they go yeah
no i get it or or do they even get it
but you're saying from experience you
came in weighing 300 pounds and look you
want to have longevity you're going to
make a half a billion dollars all you
have to do is do this
i just don't know if they're you know
and i can look at these players and say
all you got to do is be a better free
throw shooter
or hey work on your jump shot
and they don't
they make all this money
yeah because
see that's the problem
and listen once they sign you
you don't have to get better as a player
but they got to pay you and that goes
back to my original point
i don't you know you should not care
about your family you should not care
about your friends you shouldn't even
care about the coach you should want to
be a great player for yourself
i always tell people hey we all want our
families to be proud we all want our
coaches to be proud
but the most important thing as a player
you should want to be especially if you
got
amazing talent like some guys they can
work as hard as they want to and they
can't play dead you know you know that
damn you see it all the time like that
guy works hard yep but he can't play but
when you see guys
i mean i think we all
in the nba family want to see zion in
shape and see how great he can be
i mean i think everybody wants to see
that because the little blurbs that
we've seen you're like oh man
you know oh man this dude has got a
chance of being special
but
unfortunately you have to go by his
track record
i mean he got hurt he's been hurt every
single place and then you like say is it
a fair question yes there's a fair
question if we give this dude 200
million dollars
is he gonna get in shape or he just
gonna let just you know
hank just do his thing in his own way
would you uh give a contract extension
to harden or kyrie if you had to choose
between the two
wow man you really wow
dad probably kyrie
that's the longest you've gone without
talking
you know both guys
got to take us a hard look in the mirror
because it was not a good look this year
for either one of them
uh it was not a very good look for
either one of those guys this year
and the problem you got with james
you're gonna start paying him money when
he gets old if you sign him to a
contract extension
the kyrie
as crazy as he can be
he's probably one of the five greatest
one-on-one basketball players i've seen
but man he brings a lot of baggage and
the one thing you can't do in sports
you can't have a lot of back it's hard
enough to win
it's really hard to win
but when you have stuff going on like
teams they really don't care too much
about what the media is saying
on television and radio but if you have
stuff going on in the locker room
it's gonna end badly i mean i think
that's what happened to my phoenix sons
you see all the stuff that was brewing
under the table
it always comes up in the worst moments
i mean the whole diy situation with this
contract that thing started in the
preseason
and it's been bubbling underneath all
season and then in game seven
he he gets into it with the coach so
the one thing you can't have is
ascension on a team because it shows his
ugly head always you can never hide i
mean everybody say winning is a great
deodorant yeah but at some point
you start smelling what you smell like
and that's what happened to my sons
and all that stuff with kyrie man is not
good for the brooklyn nets
whose shoe is that over your left
shoulder
pin the heart away
oh
i got the second dream team
carmelone
grant hill john stockton gary payton me
rick mitchman akeem this is this is my
first dream team flag the one i stole in
barcelona but this is the second team
there's reggie miller mitch richmond
grant hill
i got a jersey and a pair of shoes i'm
in my
well i call it a workout room the only
time i work out when i'm walking to the
barn here too
i want yeah i got a great treadmill
elliptical and everything over there
uh but the only time i work out of this
i'm walking i got a bar right here which
is most important at a workout room
are you part of the match the uh
quarterback
event tomorrow yes i am headed to the
airport as soon as i finish up with you
guys i got a plane there waiting when
friction calls i move around my schedule
so uh he called me and he said hey can i
do dp i said course i can do dp but i'm
going to vegas so once i hang up with
you
i'm going to pack up my golf clubs i'm
playing golf today and again in the
morning
dan i want you so bad right now
i want you so bad right now
i hear that a lot from men
no so yeah i'm i'm heading to vegas to
do the match and i i i'm going with the
young guys too i think the young guy's
gonna do it
and i hear your golf game is
great and and and i am happy for you
because i i i saw it before it went to
hell and i'm glad that you're you're
back
well it's great to be black
hey uh
uh hey shout out to my coach dan utley
man who's made my life better
by being in it but man it sure goes good
to go out and play golf and hit good
golf shots yeah yeah i know um i'm happy
for you hey have fun safe travels thanks
for joining us
anytime my brother you guys be safe and
keep up the awesome work that's charles
barkley headed to vegas then you'll have
the match coming up with uh brady and
rogers josh allen patrick mahomes